and what i see most mistakes they make
so this is that seven step process
inspired by blake's people will get a
loose idea right here
like step one and it'll jump to like
step seven and it's a fiasco
how did the book save the cat change
your life oh it made a huge impact on my
life because
up to the point where i um
picked up that book i was muscling my
way through a writing process
i'd taken robert mckee's course and and
a bunch of
others and i liked it i love theory it's
fascinating to me and i went down where
you filmed school so i got nothing but
theory there
and uh and i made i think
i just finished like the fifth feature
screenplay
that i wrote and that one was the third
independent feature that i made
and it was um it was another personal
drama and it was good for what it was
but it was this sort of self-imposed
ceiling that i put on my career it was
um i loved the subject matter and i'm
proud of it but it was so obscure
that um it just all the real greatness
of those ideas were not as accessible as
they could be
had i sort of reordered the ideas or
built them in a different way and so i
finally this is probably my mid-thirties
i i um
got the humility to say okay maybe
hollywood knows a few things about story
structure that i should actually
figure out and again i've taken these
other courses but mckee is great but
he's so
certain his theories are all these
different really cool pieces but there
was no system at least that i could get
from his
his sort of uh weekend lecture but i
liked it i think i might have done
twice in my 20s blake snyder system
to me was an absolute life changer game
changer completely
because he has his own genre system he's
got his
own um step-by-step process um
and uh and and i took his after i loved
the book i took his weekend seminar and
his energy was
delightful just playful fun really
accessible
super smart so i learned from him
personally i learned from his theory and
i still use it now and so it just
it completely revolutionized the way
that i
think about concept think about
structure think about process
i mean it's a night and day difference
and what i use now
and what i when i mentor writers what i
help them with
is a variation of of blake's system
that i've tailored to my own sort of
professional process and it's just a
step-by-step process of really focusing
on those story design choices because
what most writers will do
is they'll go i got an idea for a movie
and maybe they'll have a character or
two
or whatever and then they jump ahead to
um
writing the script and now you're
writing the script they write like
try to write the final draft of the
script and it's a fiasco
that process is so difficult to get
right and again everybody has their own
process so
that's the one you're using and it's
working for you great um in my
experience
for my own work and working with a lot
of writers um
it's it's there's just so many missed
opportunities
um from focusing i break it down into
seven steps
based similar to to blake's system so i
it's a simple way to say it is i tell
the story i get them to tell the story
or do my own work
in one sentence and then five sentences
and then
15 sentences which is like blake's 15
beats
and then 40 sentences which are
basically a sentence for each
scene in the movie more or less um those
are the first four steps and then the
other three are screenplay draft steps
so you have
get it down get it good and get it great
and it's and it's a problem all those
and those things are
they're steps but they're really almost
like um
there's seven different ways the
audience is craving answers about your
story
and most writers that aren't like fully
firing on all pistons aren't answering
those questions as deeply as they could
so i'm good at doing that in my work at
least enough and then i get feedback and
i figure out how to do it even better
and when i work with other people i just
make sure that they're fully answering
those questions
and then when they get to the screenplay
writing part um
get it down as just as quickly as you
can
you're almost like formatting it i
usually tell like write a treatment in
that fourth stage after i do like the 40
um sort of sentences for each scene i'll
kind of write that into a treatment five
pages 15 pages
and that was copy and paste that into
the screenplay format
and then i'm just almost reformatting it
cliche this cliche that doesn't matter
bomb but just kind of scaffolding that's
that that
that um step um five
and then step six is get it good it's
not great it's just kind of okay you got
a mess of cliches and whatever but you
kind of organize it a little bit just
kind of
easy breezy momentum flow and then
after a few drafts of that you're like
okay this is working you're getting good
feedback
again we're in the reaction game so it's
not enough if you want to be
professional
that um that i dislike it's like i have
to like it and then
it's coming across other people and
they're saying it's great um
and then when you're getting that good
then you get into that fine tuning safe
get it get it great
so it's gonna get it down get it good
get it great
and what i see most mistakes they make
so this is that seven step process
inspired by blake's
people will get a loose idea right here
like step
one and it'll jump to like step seven
and it's a fiasco
and even if they finish the script um
you can see it the scripts
is a mess um and sometimes you know if
they tell me
what their script idea is in one
sentence um
it'll it'll also be a mess and i can
just like just by seeing the one
sentence i know the same
problems they have in a 100 page script
when you say some new writers aren't
good at providing answers
to questions about their characters is
it because they themselves don't know
the answers or they're not good at
relaying that information
to the audience almost everybody just
hasn't thought about it enough
um i mean there's some people that have
a laser bead on who these people are
and and um and they're just and they're
sort of developing their skill in terms
of articulating on that page with
pagecraft
but most of the people just um it's just
a little fuzzy they haven't spent enough
time going
wait a minute who is that character um
for example i'm writing this this this
script right now
and um it was interesting because i had
this
problem with sort of the plotting in the
first act and i couldn't quite
work it out and i was you know i was
like well tried to figure out this and i
tried to figure out that way i couldn't
do it and then taking my own advice i
was like oh
just relax and do something else what is
easy now so i went
over to this and i was getting this note
from this one character and they were
like who's this guy why what is he doing
and i was like
oh yeah you're right he's i kind of had
a sense of him but how can i sort of
clarify it sharpen the focus on him and
then when i did
um i was like oh i know this guy and
he's
he's great he's so swarmy and he's just
he's almost like
this paul giamatti type character and i
was like oh he's so fun to write
and then once i got that clarity i
realized oh i need a new
scene in the first act for this guy
because i had it previously happening
off screen
but once i got more clarity on who that
character was i added that scene and
then
magically it took care of that plot
issue that i couldn't get before
so that's a real world example of how i
totally used the easy way
to solve something i was using it the
hard way at first i tried it this way i
tried it this way
and i then was like oh dude yeah no
there's an easy way
don't force it and i just went over to
something else and was like okay
and then boom would you say before you
read save the cat or took some of
blake snyder's courses that you were bad
at structure
that's a great question i just had a
very rudimentary
beginning middle and end sense of
structure and i
the problem is i had kind of too many
halfway ideas about it you know this
guru that grew the other and i
remember one time i made the spreadsheet
probably i was in my 20s i'd probably
written two or three and i was it was
literally like 50 or 60 boxes and like
this question and that question and it
was just a mess of like there was no
connective tissue to it
so when i found blake snyder system
which had
really deep actionable insights about
why movies from hollywood work
and a system step by step to sort of
move through it
it just it all came together for me how
do you teach structure to your students
i teach structure to my students
generally starting with blake's method
so um
we talk about concept we talk about um
uh five story well blake talks
blake goes from concept to 15. what he
calls beats
but they're not even really beats it's
um he's what he'll have is in his 15
beats are there's some turning points
and there's sequences
and then he's got opening image closing
images which is a great bookending
device
and then he calls out your b story which
is your second most
significant thread and then he um he
talks about
the theme how it should be stated early
on
and overtly um and and that's it so
there's a few things that are
um but it's kind of a weird word so i i
kind of think of his
sort of 15 story but they're all
pertinent it's like i
for sure am writing a better screenplay
when i have good answers for
each of those 15 things whatever you
want to call them
um the thing one of the things i added
to
my process that he doesn't really talk
about is uh starting with
the you know the log line and premises
is huge and then 15 beats is really
helpful but in between those two there's
i i do five sentences so act one
act two a or what blake calls fun and
games your midpoint
turn and then act two b and then act
three
um so it's more or less the three act
structure
but it's broken out into these pieces i
mean this is a turning point but like
it's so important to kind of call it out
and so sometimes when i'm even coming up
with the movie idea for the
in the very beginning i'll kind of have
a couple pieces of the concept and i'll
actually maybe sketch it out
the five to five sentences but it's all
easy it's kind of like well oh i know
it's going to end and i'm not quite sure
about this part of that part so i just
fill in what i know
and go to the other parts and just kind
of play with it and then it just comes
together
if it's a good idea and if it's easy
it'll come together and if it's not
um coming together at least right now i
just put it aside do something else that
is easy
and then you said if to further flesh it
out 40
you you do like you number one through
40 and then you have one sentence be
each scene
that's right so for that like that's my
step four
process right it'll um and most movies
will have about
40 scenes you know plus or minus 5 or 10
or whatever
so um i want to get a sense of i'll
expand those 15 beats to like the 40
scenes and if it's 35 i don't care it's
fine i just note
oh i'm a little bit short because here's
the thing the thing with structure that
throws off a lot of people is especially
people that aren't comfortable with it
yet they're like i don't want to follow
those rules it's confining me
and they use that exact tone of voice
so but what's most instructive to me and
how i also
work with um you know my mentees or
students or whatever i
um it's the expectations of the audience
the audience is absolutely
craving uh beginning middle and end
they're craving
your your break into act two to happen
someplace around
you know the late 20s you know 25
minutes 20 you know blake says 27
minutes
so it doesn't have to be on that page
but um but if i
write it and it's five pages after that
or ten pages i'm aware of that and it's
the opportunity to go
i know the audience is expecting this
around 27.
do i have enough legit have i earned
their trust to go
longer um am i so it's totally fine to
sort of
go against their expectations but i want
to do it mindfully
um or it's an opportunity to go huh i'm
you know my i'm breaking into two at
that you know page 35 is there something
i can
oh you know what i totally can cut this
whole scene or trim this down and then i
get it closer so
it's an opportunity to very definitively
look at what the audience is expecting
in a very concrete way
and go do i want to play two audience
expectations here
or go against it so specifically with
the 40
um you know 40 sentences for the scenes
you know again plus or minus
5 or 10 or whatever um i'll do that and
then i
i um so i so i have this sort of bone
structure of how i can go and i often
put them on index cards and a board in
my
my home office and um and uh
and then i like to go from there before
i go to the script to actually write a
treatment as well
for two reasons one is um
the uh those 40 cards are really good
for sort of
structural choices and sort of thread
flow and that sort of thing
but they don't get the feeling really of
the story so that's why i go to a
treatment and then the second reason
is you know nobody's going to look at my
40 beats and really
get what i'm doing so if i want feedback
and i get a lot of feedback in the
treatment stage
i write the treatment and then i can you
know five pages 10 pages whatever it
takes
the screenplay that i'm working on now i
actually did three drafts of the
treatment
got really good feedback between
everyone then realized that i wanted to
change the protagonist from
one character to the other and then did
three more drafts of the treatment and
then felt it was good and then i'm into
the screenplay
so by the time i get to the screenplay
my first draft
you know it's not really a first draft
because i've spent so much time
designing the story
doing the treatment it's it's probably a
typical you know
fifth draft or tenth draft for other
people
you